this hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to ultimate
custom nights how you doing this is a
livestream the last one was not a
livestream some people were confused by
that idea but the last one was not the
livestream I actually recorded that and
I had an incredible time trying to beat
51 mode even though I didn't absolutely
need to be 51 mode I tried my best
hello hello welcome thank you everybody
that's been waiting for so long on this
dream I appreciate that very much and
you guys are absolutely awesome so thank
you for being here we're gonna get
started very soon but before I get
started and if you're watching this in
the future to skip ahead a few minutes
all I'll get done with this spiel I want
to say that Jack is dreaming at the same
time than I am after we're done here
we're all going to go over to that
stream so he can help out because he's
doing the charity stream for AbleGamers
I've provided a link in the description
to his tilt defi campaign if you want to
contribute to that please click the link
in the description below and if you've
been waiting here for a while I just
recently updated that so you might have
to refresh your page to be able to see
it make sense sound good okay so I'm
gonna just I I need to wait a little bit
before people get in here just because
it is a live stream and I don't want
anybody to miss it because we are going
to be going through all of the secrets
that I can find so I've got also mods
here to help out clean up chat just a
little bit but I've also got a few lists
of Secrets that I know to get and a few
things that people just want it right
away because I'm not gonna try 50 20
mode right away what I might be doing in
this stream is going through a bunch of
Secrets and then trying to knock out
some of these challenges which aren't
gonna be too bad like these challenges
actually don't seem too terrible like
there's just a small number of people
here I've already beaten 51 mode so I
kinda have a general sense of what to do
in the game but then after we get that
going we're gonna try to incremental e
go up 50 20 mode one at probably five at
a time because one at a time would be
too small of a jump to really get any
noticeable difference and then it get to
a point where I'm like maybe incremental
might be the best I don't know the thing
is it might be impossible to do fifty
twenty mode
I don't know Scott made opposed today he
actually patched the game saying that
there were a few bugs but he would never
nerf any of the
characters he made this the way that it
is just so that it exists what happens
after that is if it's unbeatable it's
just unbeatable the first game that he
made five nights at Freddy's 1 he didn't
actually mean for the 45420 mode to be
beaten like he didn't think it was
possible it was just a fluke that it
happened to be and then the other games
he just made them difficult and didn't
know if it was possible and then he did
those so when it comes down to this one
he doesn't know if it's possible I mean
I don't know if anyone's beaten it yet
but it might be impossible so if it
turns out to be something futile I'm not
gonna try it but I'm going to get to the
point where I can see that choice but
just not today so we're gonna go through
some secrets so if you guys have any
other secrets let me know mods oh mine
if you guys find any other secrets
please keep me updated in that secret
discord that I have over there and then
we'll get this going but how you guys
doing you good you feeling good oh I bet
you're feeling good because we're gonna
be doing some cool stuff so we're gonna
get these guys down to zero the first
thing I'm gonna do is actually not a
secret ah people wanted me to for some
reason people wanted mr. hippo to kill
me and I don't know what that's gonna be
doing oh yeah I did see the fort night
launch I was there in game I wasn't
streaming it I did record it because
Shawn tried to get in game and he wasn't
able to get into just in time which
sucks so bad I was there I was there in
chat being like no you got to join Shawn
you got to join now but you got to join
now you're gonna be too long in queue
you're not gonna be able to get in and I
was just like yes but I got a good view
of it and I recorded it just separately
because he asked and then we'll do that
but first thing that we're gonna be
doing is going for the mr. hippo death
also let me know if the volume is okay
because with these live streams I never
100% know I've got a general idea and
then we'll be good yes I did beat 51
mode if you didn't watch the whole video
yesterday that I posted I did beat 51
mode it's like that wasn't too bad it
was just a matter of memorization and in
51 mode actually some of these
characters didn't even come into play I
didn't see either of the nightmares I
didn't see Jack Oh chica Valora
very rarely came by like um who else
didn't really appear like Orville
elephant none of the people in the air
ducts were really a factor so 51 mode is
not that bad
but when it comes to everything else
like a beer I only saw rock star chica
once in my entire attempts but everybody
else is really fine these BB and JJ
weren't really a problem either so none
of them seemed to be too much of it like
a difficulty so sound is good good good
great great great so first off we're
gonna see what mr. hippo has in store
for me so I'm just gonna set up mr.
hippo to because I don't think even if
he was in the air duct like you'd do
anything I'm just gonna set mr. hippo to
a solid 20 and I'm just gonna see I'm
just gonna see what he does because I
honestly have no idea so if you guys are
ready I'm ready let's do this okay go oh
I know this I know this so I have I have
some theories about this but I'll get to
these later because it like these are
instrumental to make everything going I
didn't even see silent ventilation over
there what else island I didn't even
know silent ventilation was the thing
that would have been incredibly useful
when the noise was going off okay so you
don't need to completely turn everything
off but okay alright and I have a
feeling that the desk fan is actually a
very integral part of this game but mr.
hippo is gonna be charging down the way
here comes mr. hippo hurt get closer
let's open this duck to Kalon mr. hippo
Chabad Carbide mr. hippo Oh Chabad cook
this way oh this way a dis dis way oh
this way this way this way come on come
on
okay let's see what mr. hippo oh oh
sorry that was me okay come on place
this away
hi mr. hippo mr. hippo mr. hippo man mr.
mr. hippo man but my friend you have a
terrible terrible demise but you know I
I don't feel too bad about it after all
if it weren't for me it would have just
been from someone else you know I guess
what I'm trying to say is life life goes
on
well from for everyone else life goes on
not it's not for you you're dead that's
neither here nor there it reminds me of
one summer day in the park I was having
just a delightful
Nik with my good friend Orville and I
said to him I said war Ville I might
have a story and he said to me what's
the significance of the story and I said
to him Orville not every story has to
have significance you know sometimes you
know sometimes a story is just a story
you try to read into every little thing
and find meaning and everything anyone
says you'll just drive yourself crazy I
had a friend do it once wasn't pretty we
talked about it for years oh my god oh
my god thinking something you shouldn't
think or assuming something you
shouldn't assume you know sometimes I
said a story is just a story so just be
quiet for one second of your life and
eat your sandwich okay of course it was
only then I realized I made sandwiches
and poor horville was having such
difficulty eating it elephants have
those clumsy hands you know actually I
suppose that's the problem they don't
have hands at all do they they're
they're all feet
I couldn't imagine someone asking me to
eat a sandwich with my feet now if I
recall correctly there was a bakery
nearby I said to him waffle let me go
get you some rye bread now I'm unsure if
elephants enjoy rye bread but I assure
you that Louisville does now this was on
a Tuesday which was good because rye
bread was always fresh and Tuesday they
made sourdough bread on Monday and threw
it out Wednesday or rather they sold it
at a discount for people wanting to feed
the ducks and then probably at the end
of the day finally they threw it all out
I don't recall I do remember a man who
would bring his son to the bakery every
Wednesday and then go feed the ducks he
would buy all of the sourdough bread of
course you know you're not supposed to
feed the ducks sourdough bread at all it
swells up in their stomach and then they
all die it at least at least that's what
I've heard you know I never saw any
ducks
I myself but I did notice a substantial
decrease in the duck population over the
course of a few years I just never
thought to stop the man and tell him
that he was killing the ducks by feeding
them sourdough bread and if you want my
opinion on the matter and I told
although this as well if you want to
feed ducks or Birds or any kind for that
matter it's best to buy see I mean when
you think about it
breads of any sort don't occur in nature
they don't grow on trees or spring up
from the bushes
I don't think Birds know what to do with
bread
what was I saying oh oh yes yes so I
bought Orville some rye bread what a
fine day it was okay all right well
thank you thank you thank you Oh God
hang on I got it I could you know make
sure I just make an all right so that
wasn't really like a secret I guess oh
boy okay so we're gonna we're gonna keep
it rolling with the next thing as
hilarious I love that I love that I love
that about this is like this game and
Scott like always puts in these these
crazy just little little little like
little tidbits and things like that okay
so the next thing that I need to do is
in I need to get old man consequences in
the game at a level one so level one
that shouldn't be too bad right it
shouldn't be too bad at all but I don't
know what to do in here so I'm just
gonna load it up with this and then see
what happens afterwards
I don't even know if old man consequence
is gonna pop up I mean you did he did
pop up with some frequency in the game
like when I was playing on 51 mode but I
don't know what kind of effect that has
on anything so honestly you know run out
of power not that it would matter anyway
I just want to last longer
okay well nothing seems to be happening
old man consequences is just something
that pops up at random so if anybody
wants to pop out of me that'd be that'd
be interesting I wonder if there's like
Easter eggs but if you wait can you play
the game with nobody in can you play the
game with nobody in it is that like a
thing you could do no there's no way
that you would just be able to play with
nobody right that couldn't possibly be a
thing right hey no way Easter Egg coming
I don't know I don't know what I'm
supposed to do no I'm making some noise
put silent sound LaVette elation okay so
that uses power hi know you'd be here so
silent ventilation what does that do
it's using power but so what about that
what benefit does it have it's not
keeping it cool but is it keeping it
cooler oh it is it's just a little bit
cooler okay so that's handy but no more
than like the fan the desk fan would be
right yeah
I guess oh it's not silent the fans not
silent so if you want complete silent
and still have some usage you gotta do
that okay
well that's good play with no one is
real yeah that's got to be like
something's got to happen when you do
that right just like a pathetic award
you get no points award absolutely
nothing happens to you award something
like that makes sense yeah no nothing
here I wonder if there's like a golden
freddy style Easter Egg in one of these
cameras on rare occasions too cuz that's
got to be a thing to well haul in all
assumed to be beating this game so
nobody old man consequences hello old
man man of old miss the oldest old man
that ever it man hello
is anybody here no nobody nobody hmm all
right well nobody's here not that that
means anything to me but okay it's the
fan kill it with fire
I don't think 3 a.m. I also cut up like
the biggest problem that I had last
night was remembering like the the show
stage for fun time foxy would say 3 a.m.
and I'd have to say in my brain 2:15
that's 2:15 that's 2 minutes and 15
seconds because like it's it's 45
seconds for every every hour in the game
which means that you got to go there on
the hours every time the hours Thank You
Glenn Stowe love you too thank you the
cuber 21
thank you everybody that's subdue there
are gonna be rewards for people that sub
for longer because YouTube is rolling
out better better better membership
stuff oh wait okay so what do I do now
do I catch it or do I not whoa what that
do Oh
oh wait what there was an error is that
all it does it just makes it was I
supposed to catch that I didn't know
I didn't know what I was supposed to do
sorry I only knew that I was supposed to
do this and not that I was actually
supposed to do anything when it happened
kind of said Isis do I have
scary-sounding I mean they're just
they're the same size as I've been using
forever I mean I've had a pair break and
I just end up buying the same ones I
don't know I'm not an audiophile in any
way so I don't actually know what'd be
good whatever there's something to dis
because in the other rooms candy cadet
isn't there and I never did find I would
like some candy yes please thank you
okay is there anything for this dial pad
this button does valve anything tiny
buttons tiny buttons tiny tiny bud tens
you have to catch the fish gosh dang
ding damn it well wahoo I did it that I
so that's that's real sad that's real
sad that's real sad all right let's try
that again
because I totally screwed that up I'm
sorry I'm just an idiot but we all knew
this because we all knew how much of an
idiot I was so it's fine
all right this time this time this time
it's gonna go good it's gonna go real
good it's gonna go the bestest it's ever
gone dude
also I'm curious about the strategy of
actually buying one of these D coins to
remove somebody from the game and I'm
wondering who the best person to remove
would be because there are power-ups in
the game there's power-ups to make DD
not be there I'm sure that you have to
use that for 5020 mode like that would
be a necessity there's no way that it
wouldn't be a necessity to have to use
that so honestly you know who knows what
that would be golden freddy on one
difficulty get a decoy and use it on him
is that what it is maybe maybe that
would be good yeah I'm thinking maybe
then maybe actually oddly enough I think
the best one to utilize for the coin
would actually be Rockstar Bonnie
because hunting around hunting around in
the in the in the in the cameras for his
guitar is probably gonna throw you off
the cycle and is something that you just
cannot do so maybe that would be the one
but I don't know how you delete utilize
it for just him specifically toy Freddy
is the best toy Freddy's fine like I
don't mind toy Freddy toy Freddy I don't
know how he is on 20 mode but toy Freddy
is not that bad for me personally so I
don't know am I gonna do more streams of
this game yes I will I will do a lot
more streams of this game oh yeah now
when I said Oh
[Music]
old man consequences I'll feel too good
about this one
come and sit with me for a while okay
all right then hang on all right okay I
got I got a norm on I can't do a thing
so I'll just stay here all right tonight
I don't have a mouse enter leave the
demon to his demons rest your own soul
there's nothing else all right you got
it old me on consequences he's the demon
to use demon
[Music]
what do I do I don't know what to do
what do I do this is like and Who am I
looks like I've got a top hat so I'm
assuming that I'm some Freddie some
version and Freddie I don't know I can't
seem to get to the pond some people are
saying go into the pool I can't seem to
go into the pool so I don't know if I
like have to hit it from a specific
angle glitch into the lake I'll try
maybe there's like some oh there we go
no almost
okay so there's some way to get it I'm
almost there
there's definitely a way in that was a
little no okay so I can get close maybe
not him from the top maybe fit over the
bottom okay so it's got to be it's got
to be premiere because this was actually
I could I could actually
[Music]
this it might be oh-oh-oh I'm diving in
go baby go
lifeguard groaning OH
and the game crashed okay load me back
up you gonna do you start oh yeah okay
so what was blows ad whoa what was that
what was that what did they do what did
what did it do for me what did it do
what it did I don't know I haven't I
have no idea what it actually did so I
just honestly have no idea is there
something else that I need to do because
I can't believe that that would be the
only thing right right that can't have
been the only thing right it had to have
done something it it crashed the game
that's fine like I get that it likes to
do that on these things but that's got
to be the thing right yeah
there's got to be it's got to have done
something right okay you guys get back
on me on that one I'm gonna do the
golden Freddy now that's nightmare
fredbear let's get golden freddy just up
to a ten use the D coin on him I'm
really gonna deal good well you bet I'm
gonna give him that D and when I do I'm
gonna get him yeah okay so I need to go
get some coins Hey BRABUS is kandia
candy cadet to candy I like candy candy
cadet
I missed a coin I need to get better at
seeing the coins because this has got to
be like very unconscious but right now
it's is a very conscious thing where I
have to actually see and take a look
because this is gonna be like the the
deciding factor in a lot of it I can
already tell there's no guarantee oh
there was two over in the corner over
there that I completely flip and missed
because I'm an idiot so we got over
there Oh Thank You Ashley Gomez I don't
deserve all the happiness in the world
oh and thank you for the luck thank you
for that and thank you everybody that's
sponsoring like I said I
said subs earlier but I meant sponsors
like everybody that sponsors gets access
to a cool little badge there and it goes
up like the longer that you've been a
part of the channel oops that should be
there okay so I just need to Oh No oh
but I bought a decoy
wait it didn't let me use the Z coin on
him why wouldn't he let me use me going
on huh
okay that's weird I bought a decoy I did
but I couldn't use it on him does he
have to be oh he needs to be set to
level one oh I'm an idiot okay just kill
me good oh my goodness go Ally gracious
hey does he have any voice lines no no
he does not
okay sponsors oh yeah I get DD repel
yeah I need more lives I'm gonna save
those for when I do the 20 modes okay so
he has to be set to one so a lot of
these guys must have their Easter eggs
when they're set to one right there's
got to be more than that I'm sure
someone's already gone through and done
level one on all of these things
Alexander my boy my boy
yeah okay difficulty is now on one come
on where's the coins at where my coins
at what you think you don't just gonna
leave me without coins I don't know if
there's some rhyme or reason or if it's
just completely random when coins appear
I bet it's I bet it's on some kind of a
timer cuz it seems like it goes a while
without coins and then it appears like
and I think it's got to be on some kind
of internal cooldown okay so bye where
are yet come on we're yeah buddy
cama cama cama I know you're at level 1
in your real shabi you gotta come out
here come on yeah come on come on yeah
doing here Oh screw you dee dee
alright well who you gonna do I don't
know who you put in here would you put
in would you put in vent duct nobody who
would you put in oh there are deep but I
used oh did you upgrade golden Freddy oh
if you did I'm gonna be so pissed at you
God if you do you didn't what did you do
you didn't do anything what did you do
wait no you didn't did you add one of
the secret characters and I didn't even
know it
dee dee dee how could you do that Diddy
diddy video
Oh what is sponsoring do eventually
eventually I'll be able to create like a
special sponsored posts I'll be able to
do like special live streams for just
sponsors I'll be able to elect may
contact and interact with sponsors it's
just an extra set of features and it's
you guys helping support the channel
which is just really appreciated anyway
I I did create let me show them off real
quickly just because I want to show them
off and I feel like cuz there's there's
loyalty badges for it too so if you get
if you become a sponsor you get this you
get this next to your name which is
really nice you get this little heart
next to your name and as you go up if
you've been sponsored for a month you
get this one you level up to this one
and if you've been sponsored for two
months you get this one which is nice
right there ish if you've been sponsored
for six months you get this nice one
here these all go next to your username
I'm
be sure they go next anytime you comment
even it'll be next to your name if
you've been sponsored for a year you get
this one
the legendary so it's like rarity I
comes and then if you've been sponsored
for two years which isn't gonna happen
for a long time but you can work your
way up to that badge there and that'll
be next to your name for ever and I
might like this is gonna be the theme of
them and I might up update like the
graphics of it but it'll always be
always be this kind of thing so if you
want a sponsor feel free there's no need
to do that but I just wanted to create a
little reward system and be able to talk
to you guys more which is extremely
important to me they used to have a
system to do that on YouTube and that
that was really nice how do you sponsor
them there should be a menu at the top
top of it or below it I don't know there
should be a menu somewhere if there's
not a menu somewhere then like that like
this I think if you type youtube.com
slash markiplier slash sponsor but
they're they're gonna roll out more
stuff soon so you should see that more
because it was originally just for live
streams and then it applies to channel
wide in a few weeks when that actually
rolls out so then there will be more and
more stuff there's a cutscene every
thousand points I dunno about that one
I'm gonna get that one underway soon
okay so golden Freddy's back up - back
up - whatever the he's he's just back to
one I think what happened with that is
golden Freddy would only do this thing
if he was the only one in town so I'm
just gonna keep doing this until I can
get what I need come on oh yeah oh yeah
Bubba Bubba Bubba Bubba big boy big
bubble boy Bubba Bubba come on before GD
shows up please please
Bubba Bubba Bubba Bubba Bubba Bubba
Bubba Bubba bear
god dammit go away you stupid dog I hate
you so much
[Music]
Thanks thank you thank you would you add
huh huh how would you who'd you add huh
anyone on the van stuck no someone here
who's uh who's here
mm-hmm nobody who's here who is here
who's here who's here her who's here
didi why you gotta be like this why
don't you be I gotta be so cruel to me
who's here I don't know who here is and
going phrase not showing up I just need
to die now because I need to review this
no no no no no no no no no no no no nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
no open upwards nope nope nope nope
big nope the biggest nope there or nope
a big no nope not honest one not never
not gonna happen nope buddy no buddy no
nope not deeply not not nip nope maybe
no no no no oh there dammit God nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no nobody nope nope nobody nope
nope nope nope nobody two dozen open oh
wow
hello I just and me thank you thank you
for being so we're gonna try that again
I'm gonna give this TV like there's no
way that Dedes gonna be there every
single time right so if I just drop you
withered Bono could try this again I
want this if it's just like another
crash to the game that's gonna be yeah
alright somebody says look on the desk
when you buy the D coin what would that
do is there something on the desk when
you buy the coin do you have to like
click on a coin on the desk because I've
used it before and it was actually just
clicking the icon in the top left it's
actually behind my behind my FaceCam so
unfortunately it's not there okay top
hat doesn't seem like there's anything
new on the desk
Abilene okay so let's just try to get
come on , please big boy come on Big Boy
hashtag big boy huh hashtag Big Bear boy
come on Big Bounce in the area Oh
you
okay all right someone saying check the
crash log check the crash log maybe
maybe it is the crash look maybe there's
something in the crash log
Danny repel diddy hype DD repel hype -
sprayer right in the facebook get
freaked out here you stupid little girl
pepper spray blam it's just a cattle
prod yeah and then dead go on forever
big bear boy Fred bear yeah that was
Fred bear that's right that wasn't his
golden Freddy that was Fred bear which
is interesting okay so the next thing
that I'm gonna do the next thing I'm
gonna do is I'm actually gonna go look
at the crash log so to give me two
seconds I'm going to go and hang on
we're with the crash log B I'm gonna go
look in the my steam game files steam
moves no it's just
oh maybe an app data because there is
like an app data folder for this it
would be Oh
I've totally forgotten what it is it's
some subfolder is it in roaming or local
low oh no I don't remember what was you
wait yeah I think I found it
wait open with notepad there's nothing
in there I just said there's just a fine
ass six thing maybe cn4 custom night
adjust best minutes I high score no
don't know what mhm is I don't know
where the crash log would be if it was
here let me check date modified so this
one was modified a little bit ago beat
game four equals one I don't know what
that means no these are for jolly uh
slumber that's probably another
another fan game yeah no that was it I
don't see anything here I don't even see
a crash log so I don't think that's the
way to go about this I don't think it
put anything in there there is there's
like there are some options in the CN
file that I haven't seen and then
there's a fanatics file that I don't
know it so it's like Siena just equals
one best minutes best tens best seconds
best tenths so that's just time I to I
for I don't know what those mean I won
high score which is HS equal 500 CH 0
equals 1 don't know what that means I 3
equals 3 I don't know what that means
MH rich I don't know what that means
either so there's some there's some
values in the game files there are some
values in there that I have no idea what
they're worth or for but they're
abbreviated I'm sure people have messed
with those already but I'm not 100% sure
anyway so yeah someone in the unfinished
basement is talking about a weird pop up
after marionette nightmare Ian's got
them they were trying for 2,000 points
click the game over screen and it showed
up that might be just a random
interstitial put the first four
animatronics from 1987 that wasn't that
was a that was originally a goof in in
like the original it wasn't there and
then he then Scott up there at the game
and that crashed the game instantly so
let's see what it does here guess we're
going in
okay well that not the worst thing in
the world okay let me see what happens
if I beat the game with them to 1987
I forget what what is Freddy do I forget
who's even here I've totally forgot okay
Bonnie is there so Bonnie's just a
problem with the with the whatever have
you so I don't even need the coins do I
yeah none of them are affected none of
them are affected by that I just got to
keep an eye on Freddy and foxy and
that's it I don't know what's gonna
happen if it does that but this is just
an idea that people add 1987 is the bite
of 1987 so if there's something to that
then you know maybe but other than that
Oh No get out why I'm trying to do if
it's not it's definitely not gonna work
if you're you suck so much I hate you so
much
you don't just end it you know what it's
fine thanks for the power okay I don't
think I hear nope okay so cheek is gonna
get me soon
you're not I'm supposed to be here they
was out that's one of the secret
characters that chica just kill me
already you know you want to chica chica
chica come on somebody murder me
somebody no come on murder me it's right
there
murder me killing me I'm here I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna make it nice and
toasty in here I'm gonna make it super
toasty it's gonna be so toasty for you
it's gonna be toasty I've been Oh head
rush
hey it's Sammy I did a video with you
back in fanat 4 with Jack Black sorry I
was shy back then I've been a fan since
2013 hope you win 50 20 mode that was
you oh no problem well thank you that's
so nice
why is cheek you're not killing me it
chicas should by all accounts
oh hey foxy I love I love I'm gonna make
every thumbnail based on like the pieces
from Fox's body because foxy is just
like in bits and pieces everywhere what
happens if you if I don't click you
that's what happens okay alright thank
you alright thank you thank you for that
alright does that actually do anything
did we get confirmation
people are saying try 1983 as well ok
I'm not try not in 83 hopefully uh
hopefully DD doesn't come by and be
douchey about it
something please something please please
something please anything no all right
I'm looking Freddie's only had a one so
Freddie's not gonna be a bother
okay I'm looking at foxy he's making it
real easy on me wait I totally blanked
on that fun sometimes hard to tell like
that is that is kind of difficult to
tell what's going on with that all right
so I might try to beat it and if Dedes
not here then that's gonna be a benefit
but if he is here and or she is here
that's gonna be a problem use the
repellents I'm not gonna use the DD
rappel like those are those are valuable
when I actually okay everybody ignores
ignore what just happened I didn't know
cuz I only have four but what if I'm
stupid like I just was and die Oh fine
I'll do a DD rappel I'm gonna do 1987
because that was that was what the
original that was the original right
1987 was the original like that when
when the main game 1987 was the original
one so I'm gonna use that I'm gonna beat
this game I activated DD rappel so dude
he's not gonna show up and then I hear
you
I'd only be overzealous about when oh
I'm an idiot I don't want to be
overzealous about checking because then
I'm gonna be stupid and then I'm dying
still clanking oh no no I thought I
thought it's done I'm dead
oh no see this is what the hell are you
oh right
I mean I'm dead right aren't I still
dead technically speaking chickens not
there so you know I'm dead I should be
dead what's that little thing a fan a
floral dress I have man I've never
played in fan app world I was gonna play
it if he did the final update and I
should probably should still play it at
some point just do a long stream about
it but it's like man
damn it done and see it was the exact
thing I've wasted my didi repellers all
right I'm gonna do it again and I'm not
gonna screw up this time not gonna screw
up only when she's definitely not doing
nothing right I'll get this
no didi no didi
is it pissy easy pesasso
easiest pesasso easiest position easy
pizookie easy presumably easy Pazuzu got
him got him got him okay
I don't want to be overzealous but
everybody hang on I need to focus this
is the ultimate test if everything is
the ultimate the ultimate test of
ultimate ultimate e of ultimate
customized this this is the hardest this
right here hardest thing hardest thing
all right I don't know why I don't know
what chicas won't keep on to slam around
some pans but she do so I no question
it's the hardest thing I've ever done
I'm serious this right here it's the
hardest thing ever done the stakes have
never been higher in my entire existence
this is training for later when there's
actually is a problem okay we're good we
get so many coins I've got so many F
coins okay okay all right I got it no
Freddy I forgot I forgot
oops
okay it's fine still clanking I gotta be
careful about that hey foxy are you
doing whoa whoa very scary I don't like
it I don't like it
hey Fox he's still there
why my socks are not changing oh wait I
thought I thought I thought oh no okay
it must have just been it must be a
time-based thing right maybe maybe it's
a time-based thing for when this
figurine changes I'm not armed isn't
your got to be careful about that okay
this is gonna do nothing I know I know
it's gonna do - absolutely dick nothing
but still just keep an eye on I'm so
nervous
I've never been born what was that you
hear laugh
I'm so closed if we can't lose it now
hang on okay hold on all right we're
home free home free home stretch home
stretch free free my stretches my
stretches are so home and ping pong okay
I don't know if that did anything that
probably did absolutely nothing for me
right that did absolutely nothing right
right black Corvo cheers from Brazil did
you notice Mangal his references both
male and female in their description I
thought it was an interesting Easter egg
oh I didn't know that but that would
make sense because Mangal unlike the
other end products in the vent
once Mangal reaches the vent opening he
will never leave using the vent snare to
prevent her from making it that far
yeah isn't Mangal like two animatronics
stuff together like cuz there's two
heads - Mangal like see here you can see
the nightmare Mangal it's like one small
head one big head so I think there's
something to that and I think that's
what it's referencing either that or you
know both I guess all right so that did
nothing that did absolutely nothing you
guys lied to me 1987 into the keypad
yeah most of the other ones are random
chance ones okay so now we're gonna get
serious about this we're gonna get
serious we're gonna set it all to zero
and we're gonna try to go for some of
the challenges you guys keep these
secrets coming I'm gonna start doing I
need to do a challenge that is going to
get me the right number of points where
is this gonna give me enough points
everybody all the Bears on ten you want
one why would you be on one that's not
too terribly hard I want a thousand
points because you do get a cutscene
after you get a thousand points so pay
attention 1 ah all right well that's fun
yeah I can't see I can't see exactly all
in 20 mode oh yeah
that's no good old friends oh that's so
nice
old friends all 20 that sounds bad but
that would give me a lot of points chaos
that wouldn't be too bad but that give
me enough points I don't know if these
would actually get enough points do
fifty zero mode I could try that what
would that do it says nothing right what
would that do they would do nothing
right there's no one here except D D
maybe okay well this is just so exciting
right just an empty just emptiness just
sad and empty just like my soul one nine
eight seven one nine eight seven nine
eight three nine eight three one nine
eight seven one nine eight seven baby no
mmm no I don't think it's gonna do
anything for me
yeah I don't think this would do
anything maybe like a really pathetic
win like an absolute zero win so I'll
carry it over to the end but only
because only because I feel like it
right I just hope the DD doesn't show up
if DD shows up and it's just gonna ruin
everything okay goodbye you'll tell me a
story candy cadet will you actually tell
me a story
oh I've already done the hippo we've
done the hippy one we've done the hippo
one so don't worry about that we've got
the hippo that was hilarious that was at
the beginning of this but we got more to
go through this do I like it so far I
really do know I like this game like
there's probably some story hidden into
it and that's uh that's really cool if
there is but also just like for the fact
that the game is kind of fun by itself
it's that's just a series of challenges
turn off the fan never never
yeah 1777 I think you're just you guys
are just shouting out random numbers now
so turn off the fan I'm sad now
I got that generator is on all these
backseat gamers why don't you follow the
rules and no backseat gaming huh I
should probably do that if I want to
actually win this it's only gonna be a
couple more minutes so just everybody
sit around relax everybody just thank
you so much thank you so much for being
I go I just like appreciate you guys so
hard i apprec appreciate if you guys
want to take time now actually I put a
link to Jack's tilta fight page down in
the description he's doing the charity
campaign right now live streaming so
after we're done with this we're all
gonna go say hi to him and we're gonna
help him reach his goal but now if you
guys want to make a donation to his
charity campaign he's renting raising
money for AbleGamers there's a link down
the description below that you can do
that right there and also thank you
everybody that has been sponsoring also
thank you all for the super chats and
and everything thank you Eric del Nino s
space Zak lit hunter ne s Lee Savannah
Hansen Julie Bay Adam Thompson link Roy
Master Sword a gamer Shamer awesome
Vasquez thank you all so much and it
looks like DeeDee is not going to be
here so that is incredibly helpful thank
you for that I thank you Jesse Bay yeah
try killing yourself at the parent no
I'm gonna beat this because I want to
see what happens when I beat it at 0:50
mode because it's just gonna probably be
pathetic
no sign of didi and I'm pretty sure didi
wouldn't appear after all why does wait
you can see what I'm saying why does why
did Freddy have two sets of eyebrows
here or is that just the shadow but that
that doesn't seem right either what is
your sense of eyebrows here are you
seeing this am I seeing this am I crazy
doesn't make any sense
all right whatever Freddy you do you man
you do you what mode is this this is 50
0 50 0 mode is 50 0 there's a secret at
the end of the tunnel here but this is
50 0 node and who knows what the hell is
gonna happen
we could play a game of smash or pass
with everybody in this room all right
candy cadet smash super hard
toy Bonnie mask oh pass hard pass
skeleton Balloon Boy face hard smash uh
let's go cupcake Oh Oh smash pass on
Edie face ooh
parrot pass hard pass drink cup smash
smash that horse so hard fan smash Mike
smash valve over here smash Freddy in
the back there pass but just because I'm
not in the mood today
any other day probably would be a hard
smash but probably not right now
Oh triangle sign hard smash vents double
smash both of you both of their stars
Pass camera pass I don't anything
recorded like button super smash like
very smash on that one Oh
you're dead it's run out of power on 50
zero mode and what would happen there's
no one in here would that do anything
then I'd just be waiting there I just
waited through zero what do you do you
guys are getting me these secrets too
late it's not gonna happen this is
impossible
all right so what we're gonna do now I
think the easiest way to get to a
thousand would just be to do 52 mode
because I've done it's a lot to juggle
and it's probably gonna be a lot yeah
listen let's not do 52 right who's who
can we handle all right let's see one a
thousand points so maybe I should just
do the challenges okay it's ten points
per person so that's a hundred hundred
hundred one one no that wouldn't be
enough bears attack Oh Thank You Marco
Atlantis thank you so much uh I don't
know what do you guys think the high
score has to be exactly 1987 you can't
get single point scores in this it's all
it's all in orders of ten right okay
let's do this the easiest way possible
so old man consequences up to 20 phone
guy up to 20 these are just the ones
that you can readily handle they aren't
lethal this up to 20 that's easy 600
points possible from there if I don't
ever click on you that's an easy 20
that's an easy point there and then I
believe like one of the balloon boys
would probably be the easiest one or one
of the the people that like appear in
the monitor
yeah audio disturbance this isn't
there's nothing so if I if I don't think
that's lethal in any way so this is an
easy easy thousand this is an easy
thousand but I could probably mix it up
a little bit but I don't want to risk
going to two thousand because there
might be there might be something else
there so alright let's try this we're
gonna get a thousand points we're gonna
try to get that first cutscene let's do
this I don't know what the cutscenes are
but we're gonna find out but all the
characters on Macs
you know part part oh hey how's it yeah
you do
okay thank you for that do you oh wow
thank you I really appreciate that
preach that super hard super hard preach
oh hey man there's a lot of old man
consequences that I gotta catch the fish
of thank you for that I don't even think
I need to do anything right it's just
gonna be this forever and then I get a
cutscene special bonus go away does does
does putting away an animatronic with
your Dee coin does that actually
detrimental E affect your score because
maybe it does maybe it doesn't go away
oh I should listen to one of those calls
actually because I think there might be
a secret in the random
[Music]
Thanks who did you throw in what do we
got okay it's someone in here cowboy
okay reset ventilation I don't have
enough poo
I heard something oh it's foxy wait
Foxy's here okay but that's okay let
that go
[Applause]
what what what the hell did he go to
how's that fair dammit god dammit god
dammit didi you sack of [ __ ]
what did you add it Oh what did wait
wait oh that da right that's fine
whatever [ __ ] away okay that's fine I
need just in case didi does that again
I'm gonna go get some goddamn coins oh
you stupid I hate you so much
Oh God why are you so awful I know I can
use the divi repellent I know that I'm
not that's not what it that's not the
point of this right now okay it's just
foxy and Fox is not at 20 so far he's
fine okay so I gotta get know shut up
hey hey do you oh that's great
thank you for that uh-huh
oh okay alright thank you for that good
golly yes see that's not too much of a
problem I don't even think that causes
noise that attracts other animatronics
when that happened I'm pretty sure
that's just that's just yes I get it
thank you
man I wish to sell like a [ __ ] see
button like it's like there was a way it
is like one of the treaty er ways to do
this would be to eliminate old man cots
constant would be to just constantly
have the C button being pressed thank
you
so is it just like a randomly time thing
for when that actually causes to be a
problem oh there's no one else here
right there's no one else here right
there'd never be anybody else here yeah
I don't think so anyway
I highly doubt it holy dude it okay
we're almost done anyway we only got a
minute left in then we're gonna be out
of here see this one's not so bad like
seriously this one really not that bad
because honestly all you're doing is
changing cameras anyway and if you're in
5020 mode you're gonna be changing
cameras so fast that I don't think it's
gonna be too much of a problem and now
that I've kind of instincts really
gotten myself to use the S button it's
it's not gonna be that bad I just don't
want to be too flappy Wappy with the
camera so you're gonna have to get used
to when he pops up they're going to a
different camera because if you get
flappy whap a about it gives the people
out here a chance to change and [ __ ]
them changing is gonna be like the big
element that's gonna get you out of the
way and thankfully I don't have to poop
around the nose anymore I just have to
click upon her that is awfully nice
before it was like right on the nose and
it was real finicky and she was a lot
faster bonnet
oh so he doesn't change he has to oh so
he has to be flapped down
yeah he changes across okay that's
different all right so Balloon Boy I
think on the screen does does change
between them but I got this so that's a
thousand that's the thousand points but
for component B get off the pinna
thought of it all of it off
all right we got that we got that okay
yeah that was that was fifteen twenty
mode that was those fifty twenty mo not
to pretty good and told you good it came
five nights from Bose all right what do
we got Sola Tomo can I go to stat Anoka
when I caused him enough Costa what I
call see me know to nollie nice wat da
da na news Tanika
non-us tanto Cana Toyota kata sivasamy
Oh Fiona vara hos menos tio Tomas in
Dakota oh boy Akina kabocha Toma savaris
e mezzo Fudo Casta diva
yeah China kono Kodomo tachi de y otra
vez reaching moment whatis your hip
battery heavier a canonical in Agata
heavy no you na monogatari Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
lucky Donna what does your mother so you
are home to them cutting up rocks you
miss out you do at night honestly I
don't know what's happening either I
have no idea but I love it
I'm super into this I'm super into it
I'm super into this this is the greatest
thing this is the best I like this this
is good I like this so much what the
hell is that every every like thousand
it's gonna be another one of those is is
that what it is every thousand it's
gonna be another one of those that's
what the from boat stupid from doing
don't attack on your birthday of all
days that's impossible to win oh my god
okay alright it's alright we got to go
for 2,000 now okay who else who else can
we add okay this guy he'll pay is
totally fine foxy actually we can do we
can do foxy because if I'm only looking
at foxy that's totally fine too
I'm just trying to make it easier for
myself
let's see let's see here who else is not
too difficult
Oh fun time chica chica Cooper okay so I
need 400 at the ads that's gonna be fine
let's see doodly-doo one of the balloon
boys now I don't necessarily want that
we could do we could how the night
marionette would be fine I don't think
that would be too bad so that would get
us straight to 2000 so I got to take her
the night marionette just don't look at
him don't uh mouse over them click on
that don't even need to do that cuz I've
got no noise sensitive ones trash in the
game that's fine fun time she got
nothing there close the ad it shouldn't
be too much more difficult and now -
give me - mm so let's do that one just
the night marionette and foxy are the
only threats that can actually kill me I
think I'm pretty sure anyway oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa there that that was a
little a little zippy don't you think
all right cool oh all right I didn't
know you'd appear oh that's a lot of
claw things happened I'm gonna let that
call go just in case there is something
different yeah god damn it dee dee
goddamn it Dee Dee of course of course
you got to be an evil evil human being
or if you're not even you're a neurotic
[Music]
thank you thank you for that who do we
have do we have any vent stuff who is
here whoa what was that
oh I didn't catch it okay that's fine
okay who is here I gotta get to excuse
me I need that hello Sieg I couldn't see
all right nein marionette might be a
little difficult just because I've got
so many like visually distracting ones
that it might be the might be the poor
choice because if ever I was just this
is you disabled door controls oh that's
fine I don't eat door controls okay
we'll replace my marionette with JJ so
we're going back in well can't believe
this bull honky oh what a load of garble
the suit No all right so this is not too
bad this is cuz it's just foxy is the
only one that can actually kill me
oh I saw you over there so there's gonna
be a there's gonna be like a there's
something to looking over at the right
vent cuz it's gotta be yeah there's got
to be a better way of looking because if
if you're always doing because I tend to
go over here but I don't really need to
go over here it's just that's where I
end up most of the time you have to have
mouse over for that and then the the
flashlight you have to be over here on
the left side
just to get to just hit stupid Paul now
it might be it might be better to get in
the habit of every time you pop the
camera down just going over there cuz
cuz that way I can kind of see and maybe
that would cost too much power I don't
know I'm not a hard person sure oh man
you're just like mentally remembering
what's up and what's down okay alright
now that's gonna suck up so much power
I'm ROI my generators not on that's that
would be why it was sucking up power I
didn't have power so uh Jamie and turn
off the fan tried to do this hello
does he not go in let me see if he
actually goes in if you're if you don't
close it so and that might give me time
okay I'm just gonna see what he does if
I just look at him so we only so in
reality he only comes in once you
actually put the camera back up so you
have to do that maybe it might be better
to every time you flip the camera huh
just as safety to do it until you get
back then now that would be too much
power too
yeah
yeah it's gonna be a bust it's just
gonna be difficult
all around man that fan really did help
a lot when getting it down but I still
think that maybe you might have to just
get used to that
cuz power is just a [ __ ] right now yeah
but this right here barely man okay
maybe extra okay double double tap maybe
sorry look 50 20 mode is gonna be all
about finding the absolute most amount
of time that you can save no matter what
you do so it might just be better to
like get in this rhythm where you're
doing the flashlight on the little guys
cuz they're gonna be a problem you just
look over quick enough so that you can
see everything you flip the camera back
up let me turn the fan back on yeah that
fan that fans really what drains power I
don't think you ever gain back power but
if the fans off then it's just this
little bit of power that you're gonna
save so maybe there's something about
getting that on and off whenever you can
right now Foxy's not being that big of a
problem but I'm only putting the camera
down to look at foxy so it's not the
worst thing in the world
throughout there so if you get if you
get the gun that guy you have to flip
down so that's a challenge yeah you can
see out 50 20 mode suddenly becomes a
nightmare of epic proportions there we
go
but got that yeah yeah fifty twenty mode
I don't even know if that's gonna be
possible with the number of things that
you need to keep track of because you
don't have time to look at everything
you absolutely wouldn't have time to
commit to look at everything
[Music]
huh another intermission here we go
toy chica the high school all right okay
I'm into it dear diary yesterday was so
amazing and I met such a wonderful guy
but I don't think it was meant to last
from my heart belongs to another he's so
amazing and it came today and so so cute
and I think he's really into me too he's
the only one for me I just know it and I
know just how to get him look at that
top hat
that amazing top hat he'll be mine by
the end of the day I just know it I told
him that I needed help with my homework
once he's there I'll have him and once I
have him he'll be mine forever there is
only one thing that could possibly go
wrong
okay I'm so happy for you
I'm so uncomfortable I'm the most
uncomfortable I've ever been I am
believably uncomfy okay thanks I guess
ah all right I'll just move on with my
existence toy chica you got your issues
little yandere going on there I guess
yeah all right um oh okay
shoosh let's let's do let's do something
else we got to get up another thousand
and to do that I think I think the best
way to do that would fun time foxy if I
just add 20 prop it's probably gonna be
like a show every hour so I just got to
be there every hour on the hour so
that's not too much more difficult than
it would be normally so Afton I can
bring up because Afton is just a one-off
Afton is just a one-off like he only
attacks once and it's like the flicker
and all I gotta do is close Evan I can
close Evan no matter where I am so I
think I can deal with that music man
I've got a lot of noise generators I
don't think that's gonna work out well
for me Bonnie I could do just because
then they just trade spots so it's not
gonna be too much more difficult I don't
think that would be any more difficult
than it would already be I don't know
that for sure
um Balloon Boy disables my flashlight I
don't have any flashlights flashlights
things anyway so I think that's okay and
I could get one of these guys like the
Night Man the ones that require the
plushies because if I do that then I
just have to buy one plushie and that's
it for the night right then I don't
really have to worry about it I'm pretty
sure I'd be able to do that so yeah that
shouldn't be the worst thing in the
world I think let me just do I'm our
Bonnie and that would get me up to 3,000
so long as Dede doesn't come in
let me try it once I I'm gonna try it
I'm not gonna waste my my power because
I only got two left at the DB repellants
so I'm gonna try this with the way it is
I unlocked a new office oh oh oh yeah
let's try that let's do that say goodbye
to candy cadet but that's it's gonna get
so the only ones that I have to worry
about are foxy is now I have to think
about the Bonnie foxy thing JJ and BB
but that's fine because I don't have
anyone that needs a flashlights although
I could just toss out BB and just do the
flashlight ones but that's gonna be a
problem anyway all right so we're gonna
forget that for now yeah we're gonna
forget that for now that's fine lefty
active from the noise and heat I've got
too much noise and too much heat okay
that's three thousand I think there's
gonna be okay yeah okay we got this
let's try this one so I gotta be I got
to get coins number one I got to get
coins and then I got to be mindful of
foxy so Fox is there a whoop okay you're
there you're there okay foxy oh [ __ ] no
ah
wait no I can't oh [ __ ] Bonnie's there
so okay this might be more wrong because
I forgot I can't I can't start on that I
got to make sure that I don't
don't oh boy this is good hectic but
again it doesn't really matter us that's
fine can I please just get some God ah I
forgot what that was so much was
happening I totally forgot I totally
forgot about Afton but that was the only
thing Afton's like just a one-off
so if Afton's just a one-off then I
should be able to do this sorry I got a
little flustered there just because I
forgot that I can't leave the thing on
on on that one screen because if I do
then I'm just going to be screwed
but other than that that's not good okay
so if I'm too far away from the camera
for a while then I just I'm gonna be
screwed no matter what I do I just need
corns so you can laugh it up yuk it up
as much as you want a row I really don't
care
yuck it up y'all get up man y'all get up
give the old yucks a try oh boy
alright I've got ten coins so I've got
enough I think I can just go ahead and
oh it's 20 what
Oh so on 20 motors 20 how am I gonna get
20 coins okay alright we got this we got
this we got this I got this I got this I
got this I got this is totally fine
we've got about the Showtime that's fine
it's probably just going to be
absolutely every hour that's what it's
it's definitely gonna be guaranteed
Bonnie's over there now that's fine no
show yeah shows it one you you give me
some goddamn coins please for you you
where's coins please give me coins it's
almost 1:00 a.m. but I got time oh there
was two in there
okay reset the ventilations goddamn it
coins coins look at you okay see the
catch and 1:00 a.m. it 3:00 a.m. uh
that's good okay is you here yet oh he's
here I don't have enough coins how in
that he'll he'll the hell are you
supposed to be able to get enough words
for that I'm so dead oh my god he's
already hearing it's 20 goddamn coin
are you yanking my nard here oh there's
two there and then I just oh well I'm so
good yeah even like the bonus is just
three coins
I mean that's the reality of 20 mode
that's the reality of it you just would
have to oh that would be the reality of
it you just have to do that Dad
that's a nightmare that's a nightmare
Hassan nightmare okay you know what I'm
gonna replace him with Rockstar Freddie
because he just asks for coins probably
five I hope five if it's not five then
yeah what about him what about him I
guess you would turn on the heater let
me get let me I want to experiment with
that
so whoa you get coins from blocking
animatronics in the vent really do you I
didn't know that at all oh my god you do
what the hell oh and in four clicking on
him oh well there oh that that that's
much better okay that's that's way
better okay good
oh I didn't know that we just screamed
Oh Bonnie did Oh
[Applause]
okay that's that that changes things
yeah I forgot about that sorry I'm now
I'm gonna
known okay so you do get oh that makes a
lot more sense so there is value now in
blocking hunting would definitely not be
yeah punting would definitely not be the
best way when it comes okay
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you throwing in who's in it who
do you got what do you got
Oh what the what the hell I don't know
what do I do
why do I do why do you I
turn off the fan for that that yeah okay
I'll try that
okay cool
yes I did I tried a bunch of things
after putting on the mask I didn't think
of the fan my god oh my god okay all
right well all right we're gonna go back
into that one I guess that was fine we
could beat that one I just got to go
back for the show times I didn't do that
I think I lucked out on a on a not the
show time that I was thinking of but
yeah so I should just be fine if I am
looking for you know boxy block catch I
don't get anything for doing that show
times at one go
okay come on where's foxy oh [ __ ] I
missed that okay come on okay wasn't
I've already forgotten there's there's
something else out there that I need to
remember that was stupid of me
closing that I opened it so I can't go
into the camera with the clothes or else
I'm gonna forget and not be ready for
that one
oh okay I got this I got this it's just
a lot to think about but it's not that
much it's not that much I can tone
things down later by doing things
differently okay we got a 2:00 a.m.
Showtime that's good oh I just got to be
on the lookout for whenever the hell
that happens okay Bonnie's there too AM
was a Jew a.m. again I think it was 2:00
a.m.
I think it was doing it yet okay
Bonnie's still there she's back got him
got him got him got him nice [ __ ] but I
let things drop in the meantime okay all
right I didn't know that you could be
here when I wasn't in there I'm about to
die suffocating could I please mute that
please close that me up that close that
you can look at foxy okay whoops okay
who are you adding the good news is it
won't be a [ __ ] well oh god I completely
and blanking okay 2:00 a.m. is coming up
who got added anybody okay
I don't care okay almost time
ventilation here we go okay oh wait no
oh [ __ ] wait I totally forgot to Am's at
1:30 aw man I'm such an idiot who did
you add who did you add who did you add
who did you add on 30 okay 2:00 a.m.
what's the next time I can't see what
the next number is I don't know who's
where I have no idea there's next shows
it 3 is that what that says I can't see
a goddamn thing
walk you ventilation I have no idea he
was at it who was added could that got
broken who was added [ __ ] come on hurry
up hurry up hurry up hurry up
no not in here
it's almost time it's 2:15 for the three
o'clock come on oh no not now okay
that's gonna be a problem
i muted that call thank you very much
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on I'll [ __ ] you oh it's
5:00 a.m.
no it's 5:00 it's fine okay we're fine
oh come on
I wasn't even think about it I think I
got stuck with foxy on foxy screen but
that's okay there we go nope no no I'm
back on so it you have somebody that's
gonna be borked who got it that's what I
need to know who the hell got added
[Applause]
I don't see anybody I'm just got to turn
on the heater for a second okay I
thought but maybe there would have been
someone there but you got it Bubba 5:00
a.m. I forget when that actually is but
I don't know it who's here someone else
no I don't see anybody it's almost 5:00
it's gonna come soon you can't miss that
one it's too early for it's too late to
miss that jet for 330 knots
3:45 come on turn the tent down thank
you okay on this time oh [ __ ] okay we're
fine we're fine
close that get this okay 7:00 a.m. we're
good for that so we're good for that
let's look at foxy okay so we're
officially good and done on that I still
don't know if there's anybody here oh
[ __ ] what am i doing I'm just gonna
close these things cuz I got enough
power I got plenty of power that's the
thing so I'm just gonna close those
I don't know who the [ __ ] is out who the
Frick was at it
no I'd have no idea oh god I forgot
that's frigging idiot okay I don't know
who was added come on look look look
please look please look now is the time
I want to okay I got it
[Music]
fantastic fantastic no that's impossible
you can't do not add somebody somebody
got added here we go
anyway it's another intermission
soretomo can I go to stat Anoka when I
cause I mean of group stuff there is
right for event where you've already
done this one wait this is the same
thing though come the cool boy da Silva
Casa to go Mon enfant oh thank you
that's the same thing
watashi wa so mayo pit gonna what I
caused me no Co sin already you can use
katana
it is not gangsta
Kodomo tachi da what is your hip but I
like burnt bacon pork in our company are
a little heavier atsume there
I bet the Japanese that's being spoken
over this isn't even the same here
Samsung humanity de camión Scotty
Deepika no issue would Judith needs Rita
what a shorty Sonia Khanna model so
today it's Cano youkai Naruto zucchini
okay Cristina Okinawa
you know tiny Miata
yeah okay all right whatever you say
buddy whatever you say buddy boo
whatever you say okay all right well
that was a thing I'm glad that I saw
that that was great all right so all
right this next climb if we can get to
4,000 this is going to be a lot harder
because these guys are mostly just
distraction but I'm pretty sure I've I'm
pretty sure I've covered the bases for
pretty much anything that would qualify
as easy to handle like this fun time
foxy actually the difficulty curve isn't
expressed in the numbers so that's just
numbers so I don't think I don't think
that I don't think of if there's any
effect so that's totally fine Rockstar
that's troublesome controlled shock I
wouldn't never be able to know that I
could probably what I could probably do
is I could get some of the people to
crawl in the fence or maybe the the
ducts I don't know
nah that would be that would be tough if
it sound queue of squeaking metal then
close the vent when the office heats up
she will appear in both halls at the
same time what if the office doesn't
heat up would that work what if the
office doesn't heat up would that be
okay the Laura is just a sound check I
could probably do that but then that's
another layer of stuff maybe I can do
the mask ones I could do the mask ones
probably I don't have to do them at 20 I
really don't have to do them all at 20
[Music]
yeah this is tough
what about these ones where the audio
lure keeps people in place I have that
could be that could be
I can do the audio lower ones maybe if
they're all like a global thing then the
audio lure in the ducts could be able to
hold them and then I don't have to worry
about it I don't know how well that's
gonna work but that's just an idea I
could do the music box just because
that's a regular tasks that I need to do
anyway I could probably I could probably
do that I could probably do that so long
as DeeDee doesn't come in and the audio
lure does work it shouldn't be that bad
but now this is gonna be more than I
need to do so this is going to be
troublesome so let's try this I want the
next and what the next I want the next
cutscene let's see what happens golden
Freddy it's possible but there's already
so much going on in the main screen that
I don't wanna I don't to introduce too
much to it already so we just got to
keep this wound that's gonna be a
problem especially if we have to flippy
flap for that guy first shows a I can't
read that thank you that's a repeal BT
repeal live Beauty repeal hi its
cutscene every 700 is it wait it's not
every sound every thousand is it is that
it cutscenes are every 700 points so I
already missed one then wait I've
already missed one farm if I've done
4,000 no I've done three thousand one
two three yeah I've already missed one
then 700 points that means it would be
714 120 120 800 did I miss one god
damnit dingus damn it damn it damn it is
it really is it really is it really ah
tip my sprinkles well then I guess I
would have to do the next logical step
which would be
3500 which I could get by setting all
these guys at not the extreme I don't
know if that's gonna make any difference
but let me try it 3500 would be the next
one
no there every thousand okay god damn it
which one's the truth okay you're lying
to me you're lying to me I'm just gonna
do what I've been doing cuz I know it's
nothing and we're gonna do this okay
we're gonna do this alright we're gonna
figure this out I'm just gonna see if
the audio lures gonna work do you get
different dialogue from me when you die
the the hippo ducks we're gonna know get
get come here come here
oh no okay come here everybody get oh
boy the doctor saw the doctor saw the
duck Tosa oh boy
oh [ __ ] well that's so hard it's so hard
okay but I think okay I think it'll be
okay
I think it'll be okay I think it's every
thousand yeah it's every thousand okay
I'm gonna do this I think I can do this
I just need to be I just need to give
more time to the other things I can't
just be venting I think what I've done
before is actually I just I pop this bad
boy in in the middle here whoa hey get
back whoa wait just oh [ __ ] well one's
already gone how's the basket I'm just
gonna keep that closed we're just gonna
go here I'm just gonna wind you up okay
there there there no there there okay
just stay there you know what you're
fine everything's fine get the music box
look at God I gotta get
about you I forgot about the marionette
I think I think it should be okay if I
go immediately to the vent system and
then just like right away put the audio
ler and I think they'll be okay even if
they get away a little bit I don't think
it's too much of a problem because I'm
pretty sure they'll they'll just go
there because I think I've had that
before so I think it'll be okay it shows
it three oh that's pretty good okay okay
I'm just gonna keep that closed over
there by the way I'm gonna keep that
closed okay get out of there you three
is good time today
oh [ __ ] one got out one got out oh okay
that's fine Wow it was close
god damn it was close and I forgot about
that okay so I I do have to I do have to
corral them but that's not too bad
that's not too bad that is doable so lay
it down
go whine the music box and then corral
them I think that's that's what I got to
do yeah this is why 5020 mode I don't
even know if it'd be possible okay lay
it down lay it down lay down lay down
thick there we go I think I got him okay
good okay so that's that go here there
showtimes at three okay so I think I got
it Wow come on come on come on come on
ah you [ __ ]
show times at three
you I'm just gonna keep that closed mute
that call and we are good to go okay we
are in it I think they're still caught
oh yeah they're still called caught
there so we're good to go I'm almost
positive I should be able to make it
like through this whole thing oh [ __ ] I
don't have the coins no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
god damn it I'm trying stuff let's get
down to 19% power in 87 temple yeah I'm
not gonna do that
I got a doodad okay I got this
[Music]
no get back here get back
oh my god you you you you sack of [ __ ]
oh my god how the hell oh my god how in
the hell okay he's got to come back no
no I need to find them though
okay well I'm screwed then they're so
fast they're so fast
oh yeah that's right you can push him
back with the heater wait
are any of them not affected by the
heater immune to okay one's immune to
the heater no I can do this I can do
this too this way I know I can this is
just a matter of trial and error I can
do this this is not that complicated
there got it nail them okay so they're
their block you turn that off for now
catch you got there okay show times 2
a.m. got that easy people wind up the
music aah
why didn't you wind up the [ __ ] music
box oh my god okay 2:00 a.m. that's fine
this okay we got this okay
you poor boy all right so this is fine
2:00 a.m. is when we got to be there
okay I'm gonna need to get more coins so
I can't leave this open forever but
that's okay ah that was too close
that was way way okay all right it's
fine look at four
okay - am NOT not too shabby
whew that was close
okay here we go one I get that boy out
fine yes I do just barely okay this is
not too bad
okay I thought I thought it'd be someone
else almost - there we go - is coming up
don't [ __ ] with me please just give me
the - there we go
and I saw foxy over there the Fox is
looking bad
except of a nice and okay next one's at
three so that's real right around the
corner oh five five I thought that said
three but that's actually five that's
better good I think we're good from now
on I think we should be okay soon as we
remember five so please remind me that
five please remind me five please remind
me five I can't do this without you [ __ ]
what did I just do I got a look at foxy
Maura I can't see I missed that I need
God give me foxy where's foxy where's
foxy where's foxy come on where's foxy
give me
Dolph give me foxy please oh boy give me
foxy give me their foxy finally Jesus oh
it's probably almost out Jesus
okay I think I'm good four coins for now
the party again 5 a.m. is not here yet
oh god damn it I totally blanked I
completely blanked god damn it brick oh
god I totally forgot the music box I had
that in the bag I had that in the bag
totally blanked god damn oh five yeah oh
man I totally blanked completely I don't
know why I completely dropped the
marionette that's so strong how would
anybody be able to do 50 20 I don't
think it's gonna be physically possible
just judging from like this is totally
within my skill set but there's almost
no lethality to this setup this setup is
actually really tame by comparison
so getting to getting to where you need
to be like especially in the beginning
okay good you get you got okay okay
I'm just gonna leave leave that down for
the time being I'm just gonna count on
it being uh I definitely hit that I so
hit that I so hit that you asked you
[ __ ] god damn it I hit that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] see and flick I'd so hit that I
so hit that definitely hit that that's
annoying I got this use the global music
box that's actually not a bad idea I
totally forgot that was a thing
forgive me here come here come here come
here come here come here come here and
got you okay got you let's stop line
skip wined get that got it okay your
shows it three okay so we got until
three so that's good
let's make sure we're always ending up
on that screen you can let that go for
now yeah the music box just drop so fast
I got that okay that's good alright so
the danger of that is over now five
points okay we should be good wine get
away from me
at least that keeps whining when you're
away from it and that's the one good
thing I can say about that even if
there's a distraction that comes up on
the screen that does carry on so that is
nice I do appreciate that
it's like there's so many things that
need to be unconscious when we start -
oh god I didn't mean to click on that I
didn't [ __ ] fire sometimes that was an
accidental click that was just [ __ ]
rude of you yeah at least I got a DD
before everything was fine there it's
just like that that's annoying that is
really annoying that is one thing
because if you're in the camera you can
click on the bird when the cameras up
and that should not be a thing that
absolutely should not be a thing like
that was happening to me like this time
I think it was like it went down and it
just so happened to do it but I'm I'm
honored percent sure that's not what
necessarily what happened because I
think it was like something pulled my
screen down and then I was clicking on
the music box and that just so happened
to be where the bird was so that is bad
timing but there is a way you can click
on the bird when the monitor is up and
that is not right so that should be
fixed Scott please fix that right so as
again because we were fine we would have
been fine if everything was get back get
back
[ __ ] you get back god damn that one got
away are you right there and got you
okay whine the music vote no
damn there was a sliver left get good
good get gotcha punkin got him got them
there you knew this no damn it what's
the show - am okay that's easy
just gonna leave that down for now
because I don't know when like Afton's
gonna come and I think that it might be
better to [ __ ] [ __ ] come on give me
one coin please no I hit that [ __ ]
god damn it
[Music]
at least I still get funtime chica here
in the dark
deposit I know I could do the Phantom I
don't want to no no no I don't want to I
can do I can deal with the puppet I
can't this is just a necessary skill
anyway what I'm doing here is I'm not
just doing this because I want the
easiest route this is helping me like
get skills up this is helping me figure
stuff out so I'm gonna get this goddamn
it I super flub that I'm here you come
here you come here goodness oh it's too
late it's too late all right well that
that is unfortunate because like you
have to get that on the first go like no
matter what like if you don't it's like
it's game over so fast because there's
this no time there's no time - there's
no time - I guess maybe if I turn the
heaters on right away cuz one of them
what if I what if I do that I turn on
the heater right away that might control
them enough to get to the point where I
need them that might actually that might
actually work because three of the four
of them are pushed back by the heater so
if I do
yeah one is not affected by how we know
that well that was unfortunately because
I got I got knocked out of it looks too
way too fast I got knocked out of it's
super fast which is really sucky yeah
I'm wondering if I actually what if I
just pop it in the middle do I actually
need the crowd if I just plop it in the
middle would that work just as
effectively
[Music]
it might work just as effectively
effectively it might work just as
effective let me uh let me do this I
don't think the heater works because it
just push him to places that I didn't
need him I'm gonna drop this in the
middle I'm gonna see what that does I'll
come back to that later
[Applause]
work Oh God one got away okay let me try
Rick of course one got away from me it
not quite almost opened I opened it I
open huh I don't think it would've
worked anyways come that's so close it's
so close I just want a little more
control
I don't like orangey I just need a
little more control I got this I got
this spicy and I know there's easier
ways to do this I could I could do this
in a completely different way and I
don't have to do this layout but I like
this because these are the annoyances
these are the guaranteed annoyances that
you have to deal with if you're trying
to do this on a more difficult level got
him I got him okay I think I got all
them it's good let's get that okay I saw
that point doesn't want to give me that
coin now I got that lockdown I swear you
know I'm hitting I'm hitting it as soon
as I can
like more coins than I currently have
please know I instinctively just opened
it again oh my god okay he's gone so
that's what I was looking for though
showtimes it one Dede repelled hey this
is good because I'm doing I'm getting a
lot of bonuses I got this I do have this
I swear I got this I got this I got this
I got this I got this I got this I got
this I got this okay no I was not paying
attention to anything I completely don't
got this I do not have this in any way
shape or form I don't got this I don't
got this I do not got this this is not
God
I had it stroke of genius wait I know I
know how to do it wait it's why was that
not so obvious that's it have been so
obvious that should have been so ah wait
I know I know how to do it
I know how to do it I know how to do it
now wait if one's closed off then the
junction is on the other side then you
only need to plop it on one side of them
you don't even need to worry about the
getting them in the middle middle
doesn't matter because because if they
can't get away anyway then you would
only need to put it here right you would
only need to put it there that would be
the only place right right I think I'm
right about that I'm almost positive
that I'm right about that that would
make the most sense of anything that's
going on here
[ __ ] you that would make the most sense
right and I bet if I go back there
they're all gonna be well I can't see
anything anyway but I bet if I go back
there well that was unfortunate because
I couldn't let me wind the goddamn music
box that's some black click that thank
you very much you want one Oh - okay
good thing I got there one though just
in case cuz I had no idea good for me
there we go
and he's done now I can start doing
other stuff
[Music]
you am right around the corner right
around the corner pretty soon but not
now oh god damn it
son the thing that wound okay
time we're just gonna say here to boy
that would have dropped my music my
screen before I had a chance [ __ ] well
that was bad next one's for okay but
this is okay oh [ __ ] Fox is almost out I
wasn't letting it the ball drop on him
come on give me out other areas I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to survive
that that's pretty it's pretty bad right
now with his positioning so I pry might
lose this one just because Foxy's real
far out and I don't think he goes back I
would almost guarantee that he doesn't
go back why am i why am I still low on
power does the audio lower-cost power is
that what that does does that cost power
okay where I am is right around the
corner super close three o'clock is four
am there we go nope oh my god oh my god
you [ __ ]
oh my god you [ __ ] give me oh no I'm
gonna
god damn it I flippy flap that deck
what's my number one lesson don't speak
let me flappy my number one lesson is
don't be flippy-floppy
that's my only lesson in this game and I
got flippy-floppy duty repel beauty
repel hype oh man I should have had that
that was in the bag and then like this I
got flippy-floppy I mean I shouldn't
gotten in the situation anyway like with
um with what I was supposed to do but
you know I did it anyway so that's
stupid of me okay
put it right here and then I never have
to worry about it ever again that's fun
let's show 3 a.m. that's awfully nice
that's was so generous oh god I'd uh I'm
bad at that I'm really bad at that
particular thing there
yeah cuz if you don't get it on the foot
okay got him he's good okay we're good
there
come on
I gotta get foxy gimme foxy please give
me foxy there's foxy actually I don't
know why they didn't register in my
brain fast enough foxy please thank you
two coins thank you on the music box
okay old man consequences oh did it not
work stranger danger
did it not work did it not catch one of
them it didn't catch one of them I must
have added too far to the right
I must have added too far to the right
because I bet he's just slipped by yeah
that that must've been it god damn it
yeah I know
BB's laugh is annoying I'm well aware of
that fact yeah I think I had it one too
far to the right and doing that is bad
okay 2:00 a.m. Showtime okay let's not
put that up just yet
[Music]
Oh again again I thought it was I
thought I closed it Oh God God man I'm
really I'm really goofing myself on that
one yeah I thought I closed it I don't
want to keep that closed the whole time
that I'm doing that because and that's
gonna be an issue
but I I think that I think that was
better for what I needed
[Music]
okay there we go
free coin too am sorry it's like it's
like things register in my brain like a
half a second after it already happens
so it's like practically it's no good
for anybody but too am too am too am too
did it get everybody oh it didn't get
everybody but I think it's gonna be okay
no matter what okay that's great good
for you
I don't care okay oh god I don't got it
god I was trying to hit it's open now
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
oh I got this
everybody hold on to your horses and
hats we got 1 a.m. 1 a.m. right off the
bat so I can't let anything get in the
way of that I think I'm wasting wasting
an action because I'm going to I'm going
to the the show curtains like for some
reason I don't know why but in my head
like I go oh that was close
ok thank you for that it's close to
Showtime almost there ok and 3 2
okay Showtime 3:00 a.m. is the next one
nope keep that power generator up on I
want that I need that okay I need to
look at foxy more I haven't been looking
at him enough okay look at you one yeah
I don't know why I've been doing that so
much but I don't know if foxy works on
just a glance or if you actually need to
spend some time on them totally blank
totally blanked it's just an over
overload of information
let me whine let me whine let me whine
thank you you go away you get off of
there
it's almost time 3:00 a.m. is this
Showtime
that's 2:15 I believe
Graham yeah three
almost to 15 to 15 point and five that's
five right okay good I think I don't
know why that one startled me see that's
what happens I get so obsessed with like
the the Showtime that I let one thing
drop and it's like oh man I got this
though see I'm getting better at it
the lure does work I think so I don't
have to worry about that so much and
that's fine I think also like I don't
have anything that needs is requiring
heat management so I think I'm okay on
just letting that go if I really want it
to
go away in coins get Jesus criminy
Christmas let me go god I just had to
eat that one
alright lovely it's closed no good thing
I remembered yeah good thing I got all
those because that was a lot of coins my
way go away I hate you
you're not that bad but the noise
management is this gonna be a nightmare
if I actually have to deal with you guys
is there every single turn okay okay
good thing it was two because I oh well
please let me do it oh my god - it's
1:30 is - 1:30 is it - 1:30 is it - oh
my god I need to look at foxy oh my god
I didn't see a mute button for that one
he's there every [ __ ] turn 30s coming
around the back
don't let anything else drop
I wanted to eat that here we go 230 oh
my god Wow you slept through whoops
that's gonna leave a mark
[Music]
I can do this I know I can I know I can
do this I know I can do this
I know I can do this
[Music]
I don't know how he slipped by but I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to check because I
can't just set it and forget it
that's a parent God every [ __ ] time
okay I'm just gonna set it but I will
come back and look at it eventually hate
you I hate you you are the worst
do the goddamn horse okay they're gone
they were all stuck and then they
instantly got by why there's something
that I'm missing he audio oh keeper in
place use the audio lure to keep him
that day wait does Ned bear work
differently from the audio alert cuz
he's not fooled by it just says the
audio lure to keep him at bay so maybe
he works differently than the other ones
do
is that possible that might be possible
that might be the thing okay okay so
that might be what's causing that to be
a problem but that's okay
all right then there's got to be one
more it's got to be one more that I can
put in here or at least like two at a
ten okay
it's got to be something yeah yeah hang
on I got this I got this I got this I
got this
okay so if I do I could combo I can
combo these guys with this and then I
just have to do some flashlight
maintenance which might be good for me
because actually doing the flashlight
maintenance that's an important thing
for me to actually do so maybe that
might be better for me these guys can
probably be held in place this guy is
just kind of fooled by it net bear you
know not too many brains upstairs but
might like do that okay
okay yeah
all right
okay I think we're good maybe phantom
bebe would be better than mangle because
phantom bebe it says you can change the
cam and that's what I'm doing super fast
so maybe phantom bebe would be better
let's try this let's try this I think I
think we can try this I think we can try
this okay no I will not
this is maintenance okay so this is good
so I just have to think about that they
don't they're not there all the way cuz
they're they're only there when it's a
one am how are they doing good they seem
okay okay that takes a oh yeah that's
right you disabled my flashlight I
forgot about that
okay can you not can you not be there oh
boy
okay this is actually much more
problematic than I thought it'd be there
we go
got that but not the worst oh oh that's
right I do
that's right the flashlight maintenance
is is a problem because well Foxy's
almost out well that wasn't good anyway
I was just thinking so whoa oh wait
that's it well that's okay I think
that's okay because it's really not that
bad baby is just a jump-scare I thought
he was death I thought that was death oh
so that's okay it's just something I
have to get used to but that's okay I
think I got this okay
there's something I need to get used to
but I think I got it in more needy repel
yes please this is gonna be the one
there's gonna be the one this is gonna
be the one I know it
I know there's gonna be the one there's
gonna be the one they've actually
thought to set them both to ten because
they're kind of the same but then ten
might not be nearly as bad as 20 because
they're both generally the same let's
try that cuz they're both the same that
would mean the same score but then it's
a little bit more manageable I think I
can do that yeah okay let's do this I
got it I got it I got this is the one
everybody you believe me right this is
the one this is the one this is
definitely the one I'm not paying
attention to what I'm doing
oh you god that's a problem whoa they
were both there all right can you go
away balloon boy that'd be great if you
weren't there
can I please I would love to be able to
do that thank you
I care about that that's fine okay
why was I even thinking what was I even
thinking five points please five coins
please please five coins please oh my
god five coins please five coins please
I don't
okay I got this I got this I got this I
got this I got this sounds it one that's
good - no no no [ __ ] not got wrong time
[Music]
that was that the fan shut up I know it
would save power cause less noise shut
up shut up turnt sing turn off the fan
is now abandoned fence mods go to town
on it
you're just being annoying I know I can
do with that I know I can do that I'm
not gonna do that and I know that I
could probably have nothing that's
heat-related but I still I still want to
do this without doing that so stop I got
this
[Music]
oh the flashlight I totally forgot about
that wonder if I can no no it's fine
I think it's okay yeah I got this God
white you God I I do need just need to
keep that closed oh my god oh geez that
house annoying okay music box please
[Music]
okay 2:00 a.m. is the time for that I'm
going to do that Oh
para ha wait I'm screwed this time
because the power generator wasn't on
oops I thought I pressed that oopsy
poopsy
oopsy poopsy oopsy booty and time out
time out time out time out time out
yes I am serious about this don't
backseat game it's just an annoying
thing like it's it's just annoying like
the only thing you're doing is being
annoying
so don't backseat game if you want to
help listen to me that might be helpful
that'd be incredibly helpful yeah I do
know about the global music box but
again I want to do it this way because
this is harder there's a point to me
doing everything I'm doing I want to do
this way because I'm trying to see what
the methodology is at its most base
level and then exploit different ways to
tweak it the thing is I know it can be
beaten this particular way so I want to
see like how hard that is because I can
totally see that this is possible I
speed that up I can totally see that
this is 100% possible and I want to make
sure that I didn't turn the power I keep
hitting I'm hitting the shortcut for
that I don't know why the powers not
going on all the way well this might be
death for me
to death one o'clock probably can't come
out oh I thought that was closed oh god
I was so confused by that because I
could sworn that they were closed all
right reset that okay there we go wind
oh look oh we totally missed that
that was my bed all right wait what are
you doing there how did you get on it
how did you get there
when did bonnet get here or did bonnet
come from oh I know it's me accidentally
clicking all outside of where I'm
supposed to click to that you're not
there you were not there how are you
there how did that work that didn't make
any sense at all
[Music]
Foxy's almost sound so that's no good
come on there we go okay
Oh get out of here it's 2:15 I'm gonna I
don't know if it's at 3:00 but I'm gonna
yeah it was at 3:00 okay that was lucky
and Fox is part of it
oopsies whoa probably dead because Fox
is gonna start assembling himself with
any moment now okay that's fine because
I'm looking at my power if I'd have
gotten it further I think I would be in
a much better situation than I am now
but it's it's not the flashlight doesn't
seem to be the detrimental factor but
what I'm doing here so that's good to
know except right now it is cuz I was
getting up anyway okay but that's good I
was only a minute minute and a half left
and I had 30% power was it and I think
that's I think that's pretty good pace
cuz I'm not gonna what I don't want to
do is I could probably just slap the the
thing down the whole time and
three am getting better at it
please pay five 20s all I had that
Rianne was it yeah I was three sorry
totally forgot that completely empty out
of my mind I have no mind ah he was out
I couldn't do the vent thing okay so
that's a good reason to keep the vent
down until he comes by
so keep the vent down until he's there
well thank you to vampy bats hope your
day is going well I just got to the
stream looks like you're having fun
I am I am now I okay cuz I got this now
I've got this okay
so keep the fan down until he comes by
that is like a global strategy that's
definitely a global strategy everything
else is just probably time management
once I get good enough I can probably
flippy-floppy the the thing faster and
faster until I know that there's a
repeatable pattern that I can I can keep
the thing down but until I get to that
point I think I have to rely on my
inability well see like just that I
probably should have had that down
initially so so keep that down from the
very beginning until you get to Afton
and then once Afton's going I'm also
making a habit of going over to the
right three am going over to the right
because that's gonna help avoid a
nightmare BB because when nightmare BB
starts showing up I'm gonna need a
flashlight only to the left who's there
so now we can kind of let me actually
totally forgot because I need to do I've
totally forgotten what I'm doing what am
i doing leave that up just as soon as I
start to get things underway huh you got
to come back huh
[Music]
could I get Fox increase oh boy this
isn't the worst in the world but it's
just terrible so foxy is there I saw
that yeah well while this is happening
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep this keep this
down it's that way I don't have to worry
about that yeah you know a baby
okay this Bonnie okay 3 a.m. so it's not
quite 3 oh that's 215 is that no still
Bonnie why is it still Bonnie still
Bonnie oh okay all right then well
that's fun thank you thank you I guess
[Music]
[ __ ] oh wow I totally box that watch
that oh man I'm so sorry about that I
botched that okay two 15s coming right
around the corner which is exactly what
I need - 15 - 15 come on don't if I was
just like if the bear was there help her
bear okay 5 a.m. that's good I thought
it was foxy I thought I saw foxy oh you
got him such an idiot
oh I'm out of power I'm at a power wait
why am I out of power that oh did I get
I did it again I probably did it again
god damn it
I simply I click when I'm going for the
wine you when I go for the wine dee I
accidentally click turn everything off
ah
that's such a douche move I just need to
be more accurate yeah cuz I should have
had a lot more power than I did but
name and gender mapelen not bubu oh well
I would have died anyway because he was
he was not fooled by the audio Laura I
would have died anyway bye yeah it's
fine
why doesn't he use the power generator
you think I don't
it's because I accidentally click it off
cuz I'm dying I'm or that what the hell
god damn you both of you but both a yuck
the both I use I meant to close that I
forgot again but I guess it's no point
in it now you are at 1 a.m.
because if foxy is there let's look at
the sea okay let's turn that off all
right we got this calm nice and calm
power generator is on indeed I'm not
being dumb is it now let's assume that
it's 1:00 a.m. because I really can't
tell
ha no no no please don't jump Mimi
[Music]
this is gonna be the world's noisiest
run thank you
soft foxy edge of my edge of my vision
ya know good reminder good reminder on
the show reminder I totally forgot
totally forgot okay but getting better
this getting way way way way better
getting way better at this starting to
feel very confident in my ability and
then I do the same thing I forget to put
down the right thing again right away
but you know that is the way it be
[Music]
okay it's probably gonna be 1 a.m. no
it's - okay that's not bad that's not
the baddest thing that I've ever seen
they're good they're good okay let's
just hope the DD doesn't come by because
I think I'm getting to the point where I
can pretty much nail this down the
warping is not cool that it carries over
from after the effect wears off there's
a little bit of a delay on it's actually
turning off why Joe completely forgot
okay 2:00 a.m. that's 1:30 that's one oh
my god
what am i doing is that up or down is it
on or off okay it's off 130 130 130 oh
God oh I'm just I'm really cocking it up
now I'm really cocking it up I need to
be there 130 just throw that down so I
don't have to worry about it
away you call over here on 30 not yet
foxy give him a look get 130 and boom
for him bring this back up I'm gonna go
here Wow come on
oh jeez don't do that to me 4 a.m. 4
a.m. 3 4 a.m.
it's fine 4 a.m. we're gonna toss it
down just cuz when something's going
wrong like that oh it's off again I did
it I I did it again I did again God I
did it again huh I did it again
god damn I do it all the time I
accidentally click and you look at foxy
that's not so bad
4 a.m. is not near yet so we still got
plenty of time
good good whoo Hey
[Music]
Wow god damn it keep forgetting which
ones which hang on I gotta get a whine
whine whine whine whine whine whine good
god I'm just gonna eat that call okay
it's coming up for Anne's coming up
right now
no just clothes that I need to get here
in right now no no no no no I forgot I
didn't get the I didn't get the goddamn
it
I didn't get the old man consequences I
was so like my brain was just like four
am four am for him and then everything
else you just went away
man but it's getting there if I could
just stop miss clicking if I could stop
doing that
oh that's killing me okay put this here
get there wine that I'm gonna put that
down for you god damn it I didn't even
see that old man consequences that was
there but there is an audio cue so I
need to use that Oh
[Music]
okay 1:00 a.m. I'm just guessing of
course you were I think he's already
fought there's that guy I don't know
whose new [ __ ] those stupid ones the
next time 3:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. that's
2:15 that's 215 215 is when that is not
bad not the worst thing in the world
this is so weird seeing their face just
poking out oh [ __ ] knows not what I
wanted
okay
oh I had that Oh got it
I'll just leave the call there's foxy
goddamnit foxy girl
I'm sorry foxy I'm really trying I just
keep forgetting about you okay maybe
there's still chance it's fine
oh [ __ ] Oh Bobby gaming I'm the guy who
donated 10 grand to Jack's dream well
thank you so much for that thank you for
giving to charity like this really
appreciate that if you didn't know
there's a link down in the in the
description below that shows where that
is it goes right to his stream who got
upgraded oppa Laura oh that would have
caught me off guard okay I can do this I
can do this I can do this I can do this
I know I can do this I got this
2 a.m. 2 a.m. is when the first one is
to pass [ __ ] that bin it's always what I
can't see what's going on of course
you're gonna be your DD of course you
are you would wouldn't you
I needed to look at foxy then but I
didn't okay ii am coming right around
the corner 1:30 is when that is okay I
don't know where Afton is but he's gotta
be coming soon
come on give me a hug give me foxy
please give me foxy I don't see them you
there please get foxy okay I guess I'll
just go look newest for you got it buddy
I don't know where Afton is oh [ __ ] he's
already uh see I just saw that I did
that yeah
such a mistake for hands next one he's
still there so there's still time okay
danos two of them got both of them
whoa hey speaking of - all right I don't
know where the mute there is okay it's
sometimes hides really low before am
coming around that's exactly three whoa
damn it that was mine I keep panic
putting it down when I see foxy there
because it is
I saw foxy there wait no I saw did he
move just as I saw him cuz that would be
super unfair I'll be super unfair mute
that I'm not doing good on power I
really gotta really got it he's probably
gone no he's still there surprisingly
he's still there okay three o'clock is
when I got to do that dreams coming up
Rams coming up
Rams coming up and out here yet god damn
it of course he did
you still there three I'm time for now
let's go three point five okay five
that's 345 345 I'm getting flustered
again
okay 345 is 1 I need to be there 345 345
okay I'm just gonna stand that down 45
is coming up see foxy let's go as soon
as that girl goes we are good here okay
we're running out of power the
flashlights I think is the biggest drain
of power I just go here I think I'm
gonna I I don't think I'm gonna win this
one mostly just cuz I just ran out of
power there so it's a pretty good idea
that I'm probably not gonna win this one
but but I think I think I'm on the right
path here I think I'm on the right path
on the right path
[Music]
this is why this is why I didn't turn
off the fan right away
cuz I wanted to see how far I get with
the power that I have so I'm getting a
lot better at closing the vent when I
need the vent closed which is a big
drain of power so right now what I need
to do is I need to drop my power
requirement so now that I know that and
I see that like you can't do something
you can't just make a call because
someone tells you that it's the right
call to move I never work it that way I
never work that way so when I do
something I always want to see for
myself test it explicitly and see if it
actually is the right and wrong way to
do things
I also consumed a lot of power by
leaving my door down in the beginning I
could save some power by by siphoning
off that in the very beginning like in
the very beginning I'm using a lot of
power because I'm just leaving it down
for like a full minute and that's hugely
detrimental to my power I can also save
some power by using my flashlight much
more efficiently and I think that's
gonna be good so I'm gonna start this
off imma turn off my fan because I don't
think there's anything with the heat
requirement nothing in here should have
a heat requirement I don't think this
guy he causes him to have pure faster
theirs so I guess that's something that
I need to keep in mind I I mean I could
use the air conditioner when I get it
but
I'll say this again I'm just gonna see
what happens now if I turn off my fan
we'll go from there
oh [ __ ] totally blank totally blank
don't know why I totally blanked on that
three a.m. first show times at 3:00 oh
this is a problem this problem there we
go okay I'm gonna keep it down for now
cuz he's got to be coming soon heats
getting high it doesn't seem to be doing
that much of an effect so that's pretty
good okay 3 a.m. so the heat is real
toasty not you that caught me off guard
for as a does it like what the hell am I
even looking at
well the music box almost got down oh
[ __ ] I think I might be dead now because
I didn't yeah
oh wait that doesn't kill you what the
hell are you kidding me the Phantom does
we kid I guess the Phantom's never
killed you so oh whoa oh it was not two
is three oh okay you got it okay I
totally forgot that that's not a factor
oh oh oh well then that's fine
wait really oh [ __ ] totally forgot sorry
I'm so flabbergasted that that wasn't a
thing just scar me oh wow that was close
okay I got to be over there
I don't know where I am goddamnit oh boy
2:15 made it I guess it's so weird
sorry my brain is like thinking about
something completely different also why
do I have so much more power than I had
before like what them what's going to
happen to the difference in oh is it
really the fan is that detrimental the
fan is that bad
the fan uses that much power that's
crazy
I guess oh no actually no the problem is
not that power the problem with five
nights at freddys has always been
compounding different things uses far
more power than just using them
individually that's always been the case
so I think if that's what's going on
here because it's just one more step so
that way forgot but that is that's so
it's like when you're using three things
at once when you're using three things
at once it uses exponentially more power
than just using one thing or two things
even so two versus three that's how it
was in the first game - that was the big
problem with 4/20 mode originally is
when you had to have three things down
at once which you often did like it was
just monumentally more difficult so
that's fine though this is good okay I
got this
now it's gonna be using okay and now
that now that I know that heat isn't
exactly a factor yeah cuz now I can keep
that thing down till the end of my days
okay I got it but see I wanted to learn
that on my own cuz I'm a big boy and I
like to learn things on my own
cuz that's what's fun about game is
figuring it out for yourself you know
you know you know whoops
change the music
3 a.m. I should have checked that it was
like it was like one and all that way
good am I forgetting something here
probably probably not important probably
not terribly important anyway I don't
know why just stared at that guy mr.
angry man whoop almost clicked on that
guy you got a bubble why are you always
there always there okay now this is
practically easy now cuz it because yeah
the problem was like not not in anything
like extraordinary here like leaving
that vent down all the time is just
something that's nice but it's also nice
to really get the skills of being able
to deal with that because I highly doubt
that in in 20 mode you're going to be
able to just leave any one thing down
cuz that's probably like it's just gonna
get way way way way too different I did
you do that ok 3 a.m. is 2:15 almost
there but no time yet so that's ok yeah
cuz cuz there's gonna be like when you
have every seen characters in her you've
got so many other vents and doors that
you have to worry about having
everything down all at the same time you
don't get this kind of love joy you have
to train yourself with everything like
from the get-go or else you're never
gonna be able dude and I still don't
know I do not know and right now I don't
think that 5020 mode is gonna be even
remotely possible but the good thing I
did that one I did it because that was
gonna be too dicey
- spud I see I didn't see the next time
so I have no idea when it is went in for
okay for not bad pores not bad come on
come on don't Oh see it's so easy to do
okay I got to pay more attention to foxy
I'm not giving him the time in love he
deserves like oh four four four [ __ ]
four I'm there I'm there
holy [ __ ] that was too close
I don't know where I am oh my god pull I
think the music is gonna give me now
five global music oh four no five five I
hit five I hit five I hit five I hit
five on that one I hit five I hit five I
five I hit five I hit five I hit five I
didn't have that thing whoopsies might
be dead I hit five I hit five I hit five
I hit fun a guy can't be caught in that
trap where I accidentally cook the thing
down right when there's 1 a.m. ok so
plenty of time but I hit 5 no I hit four
afterwards no I hit four after coz I was
like oh no wait is it for but I hit five
first so I did hit five it just didn't
register that I hit five now [ __ ] wait
is that gonna screw me that I screwed me
[ __ ] god damn
so many people I'm assuming that it
counted that even if I couldn't really
see it probably probably counted that I
was over there at the right time so yeah
okay yeah I did next I was three you got
it you got it Bubba I hit five I hit the
right button it didn't work I might have
DoubleTap the Ba'ath where's there's got
a look at cheap foxy where's freaking
foxy where's foxy there he is give me
that stupid ice ho all right three
that's a 215 that's fine
[Music]
okay 2:15 not quite soon getting closer
okay so far so good like I said it's
practically easy now I really don't have
to worry about a whole lot it's as fast
movements at this point so that's all it
is we go to 15 go don't pull I thought I
thought the little the little bear was
gonna get me like right when I didn't
want that foxy okay doing good on foxy
get rid of those guys what's the next
time 4 a.m. ok so that's 3 o'clock on
the dot so 3 o'clock on the dot when the
next one is of those [ __ ]
I wish I wish they both like God man why
don't they both change on on on oh hang
on I got to think about this I'm not
gonna talk for a bit the talking would
be a very bad idea at this point
ah come on ok 3 3 o'clock on the dot 3
o'clock on the dot
good o'clock on the dot I'm going for it
no nope oh I didn't turn the fan off
that was it the fan god dammit ok
alright
goddamn it I knew I forgot something
everything was fine god damn it God blah
and I didn't have DD that time DD is
probably to come back around this time
oh I'm so stupid all right I got this
dive good golly good golly Miss Molly go
away why did I do that I didn't even
now I'm tilted now I'm tilted towers
about it all there were four there were
four coins in that little little little
nook alright I probably did a both I
probably accidentally hit the wrong
button and I screwed up badly yeah what
time 1:00 a.m. you got it baby you got
it baby
1:00 a.m. for you you know I'm right
there with you I wouldn't miss it for
the world when I said I wouldn't miss it
for the world in here I am missing it
for the world
no go here thank you get that okay good
okay
[Music]
the unfortunate thing is like sometimes
it it blacks out the screen and there's
like nothing that you could do to it
like no when you flip up the screen that
somebody will be there 3:00 a.m. 3:00
a.m. is that's not what I wanted goddamn
a flooding the buttons again
[Applause]
two 15s rolling right around the corner
2:15 is rolling right around the corner
2:15 is the next one here we go please
nobody ok that's good and click clock
okay I think it was five I'm not a
higher percent sure cuz at 5:00 [ __ ] see
it's like the the screen goes black for
certain things out goddammit oh I'm miss
click miss click miss click miss look
goddamn it miss click charge God god
damn it my hands move from was to one
over and it threw me off completely god
[ __ ] damn it ah I hate that I hate
that ah I hate that everything was
totally fine
I [ __ ] move my hand from WASD to e
SDF and throws me completely off it's
like if my rhythm goes off for even like
a second I am just done for the day like
there's nothing that can fix like me
losing something like that oh boy ok
when's the first time oh thanks can't
see that that's great
3 a.m. that's pretty good that's pretty
gracious of you so I appreciate that fan
is off fan is off well good thing I have
that don't know why Bonnie's there come
on come on come on come on 3:00 a.m.
yeah
don't forget 3:00 a.m. yeah of course I
knew this was gonna happen
yeah I know I don't know why I did that
I just felt like you should do something
feel like I have a chance
come on I don't have anywhere near five
points oh no oh [ __ ] come on oh god damn
it
whatever the [ __ ] you are goddamnit didi
you little [ __ ] I'm gonna just I'm
gonna I'm gonna use some power-ups this
time because I'm tired of this I just
want to be done with it I'm almost full
of power-ups anyway I can do it on this
one this is gonna be the one just
because Jesus it is I'm so tired of this
I got this
[Applause]
any minute now how long do you laugh for
how long how long do you laugh for all
right when's the first one 1:00 a.m. you
got it baby
I'll be there you know I'll be there oh
come on
click when I want you to clap all right
there we go
2:00 a.m. that's fine it's gonna give me
like it's gonna give me very frequent
ones I I know that for a fact
oh the fan was on the whole time god
damn it there I go there I go being a
dumbass again being a goddamn dumbass
okay here we go
you kiddy begone you again Jesus okay
2:00 a.m. is 1:30 we're totally fine
when it comes down to that we just got
to make sure that our bows are taken
care of before we go in there
1:30 is coming up right now for an
that's foxy was there we go I'm foxy
we're doing real good on all of these
things so that's good to know
the next one's 4 a.m. which is 3 o'clock
on the dot and yeah pretty good for I
don't really need before but I'll take
four
ok I've gotten fast enough to the point
where I can get to foxy if he's there
before the phantom mangle can get to me
which is a nice thing yeah just like
that I need to win that by the music
bucks 3 o'clock on the dot is when the
next round comes when the next round
comes Fox is still there take a look
I've been real good about getting foxy
so that's nice that's always a plus is
my power still gonna get power still
very ok
easy peasy it's easy straight now 3
o'clock on the dot correct so let me
just double check so I'm not stupid
that's great you tell me that just tell
me whisper it in my ear good clocks
coming up 20 seconds 2 3 20 seconds 2 3
20 seconds 2 3 easy peasy foxes there
with that 20 seconds 2 3 ok
ok 10 seconds okay alright let's just
nope can you not go away okay this is
not ideal because I wanted I wanted more
of a cushion before I had to get there
that's fine that's fine as always
happens
oh do you know it's 4 a.m. for some
reason for am being right at 3:00 always
makes me forget about the goddamn
marionette why do I forget why do I
forget every goddamn time I'm such an
idiot
I'm such a big [ __ ] idiot oh of such
an idiot I don't even know foxy was
there why she was there okay thank you
for that that's fine
Oh such an idiot god dammit go away I'm
such an idiot but God every god [ __ ]
damn time you can pull it you're only at
10 why is that guy ok 3 a.m. is when
that is so that's fine
all right okay it's nice and calm now
fans off powers good we're good okay
we're good to go so we're good
can you go away please please take so
much was there I think it still counts
if you look at him when the screen is
still buzzed god dammit okay 3:00 a.m.
is 2:15 that's not any time close we're
still good on time we're still good on
time boy that was close probably very
close on that one it's still like it's
still whenever I stare at that guy it's
like it just my brain just completely
craps out because I just think like I
forget to think when it happens and
sometimes like it's not so engrained in
my brain yet that the the controls are
automatic because there's way more
controls than any other one so it's like
it's still not quite there no that's not
what I wanted oh geez get 215 215 215
215 215 easy peasy
that nothing's different until we get to
where I need
I'm just gonna hopefully nothing's gonna
happen this is risky this is so [ __ ]
stupid to wait this long god [ __ ] you da
it's uh God every [ __ ] time I'm so
pissed off I'm so pissed off I'm so glad
I should have had this like ten attempts
ago I should have had this ten attempts
ago this is not that hard
[Music]
god damn it every time so mad at myself
when's the first time 2 a.m. 2 a.m. is
the first it's got it for those who you
don't even know what happened the the
helper guides he pulls your monitor down
if you don't get him so going up and
waiting up there I was like this is
gonna take too long and then I'm never
gonna be able to get to where I need to
be in time it's gonna like I am NOT
checking up and then I'm gonna be dunzo
so that's that's what that was all about
everything's good power management's
good we're good - 30s coming up - 30s
coming up but it's not here yet almost
here ok it's time I'll go for it now and
5 a.m. that's good that's good that's
good that's plenty of time I just took a
gamble on that one I wasn't sure which
one it would be at the time we got 5 am
which is 3:45 I believe 3:45 so plenty
of time mm now I see a man so many
things is getting your way you have to
just like gather information from just
such a small glimpse that it just ends
up being this this super super super
challenging like mental agility test
which is something the mute button is
gone
goddamnit sometimes it just happens like
the mute button is there cuz I saw it I
definitely saw it the mean button was
there
[Applause]
okay 5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m.
345 345 345
3:45 getting closer it's almost there
3:45 unless they're not there yet though
not there yet so no need to panic no
need to change anything not there you
didn't close now there we go not there
yet so don't get ahead of myself get the
ventilation down okay get in there go
ahead here let's know
[Music]
okay we got this what happened there was
I forgot like I was so concentrated on
the time that I forgot
Oldman I didn't even see old man
consequences there old man consequences
got in my way and just completely boned
me I had I'm wasting all my power-ups -
what the hell just happened oh I went in
that's god damn it oh [ __ ] me - [ __ ]
playa
ah God if you go into the challenge menu
just erases everything okay great yeah
that's fun thank you for that
it's really [ __ ] great thank you so
happy that I have to redo this again so
happy about this i'ma be super happy
super happy you're happy that I have to
do this again
god dammit I have it it's just so easy
okay it's just forgetting things that's
the only thing that's getting me just
forget it my brain just isn't
multitasking enough god that sucks so
bad
[Music]
I'm so mad I'm so mad god I had that
million ways I had that come up what did
i have you guys you [ __ ] so myself
what am I missing
God him somebody you do oh I'm so mad
like of course of course of course
just like the end and at the exact
timing to like the [ __ ] timing oh god
this is why I'm never gonna be able to
do 50 20 of this I mean I might be able
to but I'm not gonna want to okay I
think of these you guys we're supposed
to be done in 10 my power-ups here yeah
here okay let's just do it again
[ __ ] I got this everybody hold on I know
you all have your opinions and like
advice I don't care just ignore it let
it let bygones be bygones I will get
this when i get it and i get it is when
i get it no sooner no later no sooner no
later i turn the fan off
good [ __ ] of course god god [ __ ]
damn it [ __ ] what the [ __ ] again god
damn it [ __ ] me [ __ ] everything oh it's
so mad
Oh forgot to turn oh my god I forgot to
turn you guys off go away go I go I go I
go okay you're off the ends off okay
we're good
when's the first show god damn it of
course now when's the first shot 1 a.m.
okay we're just gonna sit here we're
good when the next show is at 4 a.m.
that's it all right thank you that's
real nice of you go away please that'd
be really cool I haven't looked at foxes
god dammit Oh God it's like it's trying
to make me mad it's like it's trying
it's like it's [ __ ] trying god
[ __ ] day you put the bird there I
hate that I hate it so much [ __ ] bird
[Music]
no I didn't activate the powerup Scott
well whatever it's gonna be Dee Dee's
gonna be all over me this time around
you know Dee Dee's gonna be all over me
this time around because that's how it
always works put an over/under on how
many times DB is gonna come out this one
time because I didn't activate my
power-ups over under someone give me two
I'm gonna go with - I'm gonna go with
two short ends at 1 a.m. I'm gonna go
with two I think that seems like a good
fair estimate don't pull me away thank
you - okay we're gonna have a lot of
them we're gonna have a lot of them
that's fine I don't see a mute button
maybe there was one but I didn't I'd
like to see foxy at some point okay - is
coming up comes too
[Music]
[Applause]
four four that's three on the dot three
on the dot is next one damn it
I don't let go warping because it moves
the location it physically moves the
location of the button or maybe it
doesn't maybe actually wait I don't want
to make it I don't want to make a claim
to that yet because I actually don't
know what specifically it does okay
three clocks coming up 20 seconds by of
87 yeah is amazing got that 5 a.m. okay
so that's fine we can do 5 that's 3:45
so that's right around the corner that's
fine and I'll worried about that
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up
15 seconds got it and got that 7:00 a.m.
okay we do not need to worry about that
anymore that was fun
glad we don't have to do that just got
to keep this music box wound and this is
in the bag ain't that's fun I think we
got this one finally we got this one oh
[Applause]
well they're really coming at me right
at the end here though they really don't
want me to leave here they're really
laying it on thick pool boy well are
they laying it on thick oh now they're
not oh I called them out on their BS
least dd-didn't decided to screw with me
tonight
thank you thank you DeeDee Thank You
DeeDee yay I did it good god see it
wasn't that hard at the end there but it
just took a long time for me to like
internalize it like that's how my brain
works with this sort of stuff it takes
time for me to process what's going on
and make it instinctual because the only
way that you're able to do this you
can't consciously go oh
Foxy's in there I need to go there you
need to just be like
remove the words from any equation er
like no words like words cannot get in
the way of your thinking when you're
doing this sort of stuff
any time I was doing a 420 Modi's like
you have to do it until it becomes
instinctual that's the only way that you
can keep it going there so let's see
what's going on is it gonna be the chika
high school one notice dear diary
yesterday was so amazing and I met such
a wonderful guy but I don't think it was
meant to last from my heart belongs to
another he's so amazing didn't it's the
same thing I'm so so cute it's the same
thing and I'm still just as weirded out
about it I think he's really into me too
yeah don't look at me like that I don't
like that she keeps looking into the
camera untamed Oh No amazing silky Sheen
oh he'll be mine by the end of the day I
just know it I told him that someone ran
over his dog in front of my house but
once he's there
I'll entice him with warm cookies lure
him inside I mean invite him inside and
then I'll have him and once I have him
he'll be mine forever there is only one
thing that could possibly go wrong
okay that's extremely disturbing
extremely extremely disturbing it's
expressly disturbing it that's
expressing but their dad done got it oh
my god but shouldn't have taken that
long but again like the reason I do this
is I like I know I sound like a dick
when I'm like oh give me any advice
because I don't want advice because
advice is not me figuring it out when
you play this if you want to be able to
beat this you can't
it through advice you need to do it
yourself you need to build muscle memory
that's the only way that it works
why is my camera like lagging behind I
have no idea why that's out of sync but
that's the only way that it works what
the hell is happening with this thing
why is my camera lagging so laggy cuz it
have been like that ha ha
there we go better now god dammit how
long has that been like that how long as
I've been just screaming off like just a
few minutes off from what I was doing
okay anyway so that is enough for part 2
part 3 we'll go through the challenges
and start the climb and then as we get
better about it we'll get more and more
and more and more and more and more
things will get more intermissions maybe
more secrets will be unearthed and then
I will start the road to getting to see
if I can do any sort of 5020 mode
that'll be part two that live stream
will probably happen tomorrow but for
now I'm all done so now go check out I
think he's probably definitely still
streaming he's probably definitely
almost incredibly absolutely probably
maybe still streaming yeah okay so
jacksepticeye is streaming right now for
charity go there now thank you everybody
so much for the super chats the
sponsorships it means the world to me
and thank you everybody that is donated
through the tilta fide links go to
Jack's page he is streaming right now
for AbleGamers charity he's playing
crash bandicoot go check him out support
the charity thank you everybody so much
for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye guys bye this will be
uploaded afterwards so don't worry about
that bye bye bye bye goodbye